and welcome to hannity all right we
begin with news just breaking right now
at this minute and we we start with a
fox news alert now according to a
breaking new report from politico the
u.s supreme court has in fact voted to
overturn roe versus wade if this report
turns out to be true abortion will now
be regulated at the state level
meaning it is not going to be illegal
probably in most states in the united
states there will be varying
restrictions
one of the biggest issues involving this
case has to do with whether or not
whether or not roe v wade and this is
what conservatives have often believed
uh constitutionalists have believed
originalists have believed is that it
enumerated a right that did not exist
within the constitution what's
interesting about this is the draft
opinion unfl flinching repudiation of
the 73 decision guaranteeing
a
federal
constitutional protection on abortion
rights uh as they report in in politico
planned parenthood versus casey that
largely maintained that right
if this report is true justice alito
writes roe was egregiously wrong from
the start and we hold that roe and casey
must be overruled he writes in the
document labeled quote opinion of the
court uh it is time to heed the
constitution return the issue of
abortion to the people's elected
representatives that's where the issue
of judicial philosophy comes into play
do you enumerate a right not
specifically spelled out in the
constitution or should it be up to the
states which is what conservatives have
always argued uh deliberations on
controversial cases have in the past
been fluid justices can and sometimes do
change their votes and opinions
uh as their opinions are circulated
among the the different supreme court
justices major decisions can be subject
to multiple drafts vote training
sometimes until just days before the
decision is unveiled
um but the the real heart of alito's
words if in fact this remains the final
decision would be roe was egregiously
wrong from the start its reasoning was
exceptionally weak and the decision has
had damaging consequences and far from
bringing about a national settlement of
the abortion issue roe and casey have
inflamed debate and deepened division in
this country
uh if we look at what they're reporting
a person familiar with the deliberations
according to politico
said that four other republican
appointed justices clarence thomas neil
gorsuch brett kavanaugh amy coney
barrett
voted with alito in the conference and
held among the justices after hearing
oral arguments this is back in december
we don't expect the final decision until
sometime in june maybe july even usually
in may or june
uh but the three democratic appointed
justices briar sotomayor kagan are
working
on one or more descents that would be
part of any final decision that comes
out
but it's going to be interesting to
watch this will
absolutely be demagogued by
the left in the country
but at the end of the day uh
we the document labeled as a first draft
of the majority opinion it would
indicate
they may be leaning as of tonight to
overruling roe v wade that is considered
a precedent
the inescapable inescapable conclusion
is the right of to an abortion is not
deeply rooted in the nation's history or
traditions the constitution does not
prohibit the citizens of each state from
regulating or prohibiting abortion the
draft concludes in other words abortion
will not be made illegal by the federal
government it will be up to the states
to decide rowan casey
uh abrogated that that authority we now
overrule these decisions and return that
authority to the people and their
elected representatives we'll have a lot
more on this breaking news straight
ahead tonight
uh but this is this is pretty
interesting now just to be very clear
here even though this is a draft
uh
sounds like the likelihood that's where
their their decision is headed towards
so we'll watch this very closely hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else